episodio 3
[Música]
bienvenidas al podcast directo con lo
cual continuamos platicando sobre la
diversidad sexual
qué tiene que preguntar la respuesta a
una pregunta que me hicieron respecto a
la situación que compartían xxi anterior
sobre mi acoso escolar la pregunta es
cómo haría algo que hubiera sido el
mejor forma de abordar la situación a
nivel grupos que como ya su vez también
fue una pregunta camisa de género quise
invitar a una persona en esta ocasión
viene a plantear que damos un punto de
vista como un profesional
así es que vamos a comenzar
o no
soy alma hernández soy mamá de oscar
pero también ahora tuve elaborando 34
años y tengo mucha mucha experiencia
adquirida en esos años y bueno yo
considero que esta situación se pudo
haber abordado de una manera
satisfactoria
haciéndolo tal vez con un proyecto a
nivel escolar
porque digo que a nivel escolar porque
cuando llega un chico a la escuela a un
aula un salón de clases ese chico no es
nada más de ese salón de clases nada más
de esa maestra ni de sus compañeros de
los que se rodean dentro de su aula
llega a la escuela ve a otras maestras
me a otros niños de otros grados padres
de otros grados de otros salones en
recreo se relacionan también con ellos y
yo creo que una forma muy acertada de
haberlo abordado hubiera sido justamente
ese proyecto escolar en donde se
hablarán no precisamente de una
situación en especial en cuanto al tema
del que se está tratando sino a nivel
universidad porque porque de esa forma
tú hablas de la sensibilidad que todos
como sociedad scola debemos de tener con
los niños de todas las proveniencias de
familias de alguna discapacidad de
diversa índole motriz auditiva con
autismo
de esa forma no tendría por qué
centrarte en un solo niño ni en el caso
de un niño que se hablan y se
sensibilizar tanto a padres maestros y
alumnos para que ellos cuando noten
cierta situación
diferente a lo que se ha trabajado en el
proyecto
el proyecto obviamente tiene tiene un
curso tiene un inicio se trabaja a base
de situaciones didácticas en donde se
van dosificando los temas que se van a
abordar
pudiese haber sido por grupos un grupo
habla de discapacidad auditiva otro
grupo de autismo otro grupo de niños con
familias monoparentales el bagaje es muy
amplio pero a lo que se quiere llegar es
a la atención a la universidad y que esa
comunidad educativa tenga esa
sensibilidad para poderse identificar o
incluir a los niños a los padres porque
también hablamos de padres como como yo
como papá de un niño con discapacidad o
con ciertas características como me
siento como papá entonces otro papá de
otro grupo también me entiende que si mi
niño está en cierta condición yo como
papá como lo estoy viviendo entonces
creo que esa hubiera sido la forma o al
menos en mi comunidad escolar de esa
forma yo lo hubiese atacado
qué consejo podrías darles a los padres
de familia siempre se los dije un lema
un consejo que me atrevía a brindarles a
las madres de familia ya los padres y
bueno abuelitos también porque haya
bonitos que suplen a los papás hay
cuidadores que decía que nunca apuesten
de la mano a sus niños estén en la etapa
que estén en desde preescolar hasta
preparatoria universidad de ser posible
abrir siempre acompañándolos obviamente
en las etapas son muy diferentes del
acompañamiento que los chicos requieren
es diferente en cada etapa sin embargo
creo que eso es una parte muy importante
en donde los padres siempre deben estar
pendientes de sus hijas pendientes creo
que cambiando la actitud habitual de
alguna forma acudirá a pedir ayuda tal
vez a veces se cierran en o kidd en
sabero o dar a conocer a otra persona
tal o cual situación que les pueda pasar
pero yo los invito a que se acerquen a
sus compañeros padres de familia a sus
maestros al equipo de trabajo que preste
los servicios en el lugar donde lleven a
sus chicos a la escuela no dude en no
duden en acercarse y en abrir su corazón
para que sean atendidas es fácil quietud
es que como padres deben de tener yo sé
que en las escuelas hay buen personal
hay maestros que de verdad somos de
vocación y que estamos para el servicio
y atención de sus niños como adultos
definitivamente cuando un chico es
acosado goleado siempre va a tener un
cambio en su conducta habitual
normalmente son chicos que se empiezan a
aislar con chicos que en los recreos
permanecen solos que muchas veces me
llevo a mi a tocar niños debajo de los
pupitres niños que se van al baño porque
simplemente no quieren estar dentro de
un salón muchas veces me tocaron niños
que yo tenía que ir auxiliar y llevarme
los a la dirección para hablarles un
poquito más de seguridad sin embargo no
queda ahí eso es en la escuela pero como
madres yo creo que ustedes conocen a sus
niños tú cómo sabes perfectamente cómo
son tus hijos cualquier red cualquiera
por insignificante que sea puede ser
desde que ese aislamiento que moje en la
cama que se les vaya el apetito que no
quiera la equis lugar o que no quieran
saludar a una persona todo eso son
signos de que un chico está pasando por
algo difícil sobre todo exhortar de ti
padre madre de familia que busques
atención de fuentes fidedignas que no te
dejes llevar por lo que ahora los
jóvenes se estilan mucho acudir de
inmediato a buscar todo en google no
digo que eso no sirva no es una
herramienta muy importante y muy actual
sin embargo recuerden que cada niño es
diferente entonces un caso de un chico
en particular no es una receta de cocina
que puedas encontrar en internet
este chico tiene su historia tiene su
ambiente familiar tiene sus vivencias
desde cómo fue concebido en qué
condiciones y fue un niño
como la mamá lo es pero estaba feliz
estaba de recibirlo también fue a un
niño que fue concebido por equis o ye
situación a lo mejor no fue deseado todo
eso entonces justamente como un niño
trae esa historia de tan personal nos
podemos encontrar en un google no nos
puede dar la receta y así se va a curar
su niño
por eso la sigo exhortando a que vayan
con el personal citado para cada caso
sean especialistas de la escuela sean
psicólogas psicopedagogas y villarreal o
que ustedes vayan necesitando se les
vaya llevando de la mano desde su
escuela ahí van a empezar a identificar
algún chico con alguna problemática
llámese cualquiera y de ahí los van a ir
canalizando a las instancias muchas
gracias por todo su conocimiento por tus
comentarios
[Música]
o no
y antes de terminar este episodio
después de esta gran intervención vamos
a platicar un poquito más sobre consejos
que se pueden dar para que los padres
detecten si los hijos hijas o hijas
están sufriendo acoso escolar
[Música]
ya sea que se encuentra en zonas de
juego de la escuela o en el parque del
vecindario los niños a veces terminan
siendo víctimas de los acosadores cuando
esto sucede los mismos tiradores pueden
1 amedrentar al niño 2 hacerlos sentir
menos
3 arruinar su juego
4 causarle daño físico o 5 causarle
problemas mentales duraderos
[Música]
evitar a un acosador es una razón por la
cual su hijo puede mostrarse renuente a
asistir a la escuela quizás esté
sintiendo obligado a cederle a su
acosador el dinero de su loans o quizá
podría tener miedo de que lo lastimen
físicamente si tiene sospechas de que
existen problemas como éste debe tomar
medidas para garantizar la seguridad y
el bienestar de su hijo estas son
algunas estrategias que puede adoptar su
hijo con ayuda y que lo ayudarán a
sentirse más seguros
dígale a su niño que no reaccione ante
el acosador ni ceda ante sus exigencias
un acosador se deleita al intimidar a
los demás y no hay nada que le guste
tanto como ver a su víctima llorar o que
se esté molesto de otras maneras obtener
esta respuesta refleja el comportamiento
acosador su hijo debe intentar mantener
su compostura y simplemente alejarte
luego debe comunicarle a un adulto que
está sucediendo
lo más pronto posible los dos si no
resultan en los intentos de su hijo por
ignorar los fastidios de un acosador su
niño debe permanecer firme y mantenerse
erguido y ver a los otros a sus
tiradores y expresar claramente y en voz
alta algo como deja de hacer esto ahora
mismo y continuando voy a denunciar ante
el director y te hablo pero no voy a
pelear así que baja tus impulsos
algunas veces una expresión fuerte
calmará la situación y el acosador
tratará de encontrar otro blanco más que
el hecho de atraer la atención de los
compañeros hacia la situación de acoso
puede avergonzar al acosador si un niño
no está acostumbrado a reaccionar de
manera asertiva
ayúdelo ensayar lo que va a decir si se
ve confrontado 3 hablar con el pediatra
puede beneficiar al niño el pediatra
puede decir si el niño sufre en algún
momento un problema mental debido al
acoso y puede referir a los
especialistas de salud mental para más
de evaluaciones y tratamientos
4 insiste a su niño a que forme lazos
sólidos de amistad un joven que tiene
buenos amigos tienen menos probabilidad
de ser el blanco de un acosador o por lo
menos tiene algunos aliados en caso de
que se vuelva un objeto de acoso 5
hablé con el maestro o con la maestra de
su hijo o con el director en caso de que
persista la situación con el acosador es
posible que usted se rehúsa a intervenir
porque su niño se vaya a avergonzar de
que lo hace o porque cree que él
necesita lidiar con estas situaciones
por otro lado no quiere que la
autoconfianza de su niño se debilite lo
que está en riesgo su bienestar físico
su hijo merece asistía a la escuela de
momento con seguro aún cuando está
significa que tanto usted como el
personal de la escuela deban
involucrarse y por último deje que el
director de la escuela o el maestro
hable directamente con el niño tirador
cuando vea el comportamiento inapropiado
en la escuela esto funciona mejor que el
tratar de hablar con él o con sus padres
[Música]
o no
déjenme saber sus comentarios dudas
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
las encuentran como árbol podcast
elegiré tecú voy a adicionar un link en
la descripción del episodio para que
puedan llegar a cada una de ellas
recuerden que dar un la aventaron
compartir dar un suscribirse en youtube
ayuda mucho para que toda esta
información puede llegar a más y más
personas y de esta manera nos
encaminemos a hacer esa sociedad que
vive incluye respetar
con la universidad no me queda más que
recordarles que mi nombre es oscar olmos
y que nos escuchamos en el próximo
episodio para continuar construyendo
conocimiento derribando prejuicios
[Música]